Okay, we're going to do a very special
short about protecting the future of
Gary's economics. So, we are opening a
mailing list. Um, as we grow and get
more and more politically powerful, we
become aware that our increasingly quite
large political power is at risk of
future things happening like getting
chucked off of YouTube, like getting
chucked off of Instagram. And we think
it's probably best that we build a
mailing list just in case that ever
happens so that we can stay in touch
with you if we ever get deplatformed,
which is something in the long term
which definitely could potentially
happen. So, we're setting up a mailing
list. Um, we might use it to use a
newsletter, but really it's just to
protect our political robustness. Um,
and yeah, it helps us to grow power. It
helps us to influence politicians. So,
we're setting up a mailing list. The
link should be in the bio in the
description or maybe around here
somewhere. If you're on Instagram, um,
sign up. Um, it helps us protect
ourselves if uh the tech billionaires
ever decide to come for us, which uh if
we keep growing, maybe one day they
will. Um, thank you very much. Sign up
to the mailing list. Thanks for all your
support. The tax does not work.